summer doesn't have to end at north
italia and as they continue to mix up
their summer sips menu joining us today
from north italia we have executive chef
will lentz and bar manager janelle grady
thank you guys for being here thank you
thank you for having us i was just
telling you guys that i used to live in
arizona and we'd go to north italia all
the time so i was so excited when you
guys opened a las vegas location it's
absolutely delicious but let's get right
to it this summer sips menu something
that does happen across all north italia
locations but what is it you guys mix up
the menu every week so every year we
give our bartenders a chance to shine
and feature their local ingredients with
our italian spirits so we have 10
regions across the country and this
year's winner for our region was
michelle green from arizona and this was
her cocktail and it is called the
farfalla viola
which means purple butterfly oh my gosh
and it is inspired using fresh lemon
juice which we use all fresh juices and
ingredients in the kitchen and then our
italian spirits which are featured here
the botek of occurred gin which is an
italian gin we have aviation which is
infused with butterfly pea flower which
makes it the deep purple we have our
starlino which is another italian
liqueur and then the fiorente which is
an elderflower liqueur well just every
ingredient sounds beautiful and i'm
going to call this the butterfly drink
because it's so cute can we make it can
we show our viewers what's inside of it
and so while you're making it too how
long is this available through so we're
going to have this available until
september 22nd and we will kick off a
finale for the end of summer and we will
feature an all-day happy hour oh okay
sounds amazing i'll let you get started
on the drink because i'm excited to try
this so we have simple syrup which is
basically
sugar water i love it half ounce of that
we have a half ounce of fresh squeezed
lemon juice
very light and refreshing
a half ounce of the fiorente which is
the elderflower liqueur
love it and then the starlino
which is another italian liqueur it's
pretty kind of looks like a rose
everybody loves rosie yes
the bottega decor which is
an ounce and a half okay a little more
of that
and then what we're going to do is we're
going to pour
a half ounce of the infused look at that
color it's beautiful so it starts off a
deep blue wow okay you start chicken
over here what does this pair well with
so
this is a gin based drink okay nice and
light summertimey drink pairs well with
a multitude of dishes on our menu we
chose our shrimp scampi here we have a
there's a bunch of dry vermouth in there
okay
that goes super well with the gin as
well
shrimp gin classic combo right there
perfect combo so let's see i'll have you
put it together because it all smells
amazing already what we do is we start
with our house-made garlic butter
so good
and i always say you can tell a lot
about an italian restaurant when you go
in and the bread is good because that's
the very first thing so it just leads
you into a great meal so okay let's get
100
so a little bit of roasted garlic confit
okay blistered cherry tomatoes okay
we have about 45 seconds left so i'm
gonna have you throw it all in
the shrimp the magic of tv here top that
with a little bit of cheese pop that in
the oven and then this is going to be
our final product there this looks
amazing so this pairs with this
beautiful cocktail we'll top it off over
here the citric acid in the lemon juice
hits the butterfly pea flour it goes
from a deep blue to a purple
just look at this color you guys this is
beautiful this is the perfect summer
cocktail i think perfect year-round
cocktail but you guys thank you so much
for being here
i'm going to try this drink but i'm sure
it's delicious be sure to go check out
north italia they're right on rampart
and any more locations coming to vegas
soon soon can't say hopefully all right
we're we're cheers thank you guys all
right i'll send it over